So the daily White House coronavirus press
briefings have really been the stuff of horrors
in a number of ways.
We see lies, endless lies from Trump.
We see delusions from his taskforce.
We see the bullying of the doctors on the
task force into having to be really careful
and sort of walk on eggshells and be very
careful in how they couch what happened and
what needs to happen for fear of angering
Donald Trump.
We see Trump never answering the questions
of reporters.
We're really seeing it all.
But yesterday was a true authoritarian nightmare,
with Donald Trump furiously yelling at the
room, calling most of the reporters in the
room fakes, which we'll get to.
And there is so much here, but it is all founded
in Donald Trump's incipient
narcissistic authoritarianism.
And I'm not going to go in chronological order
here, but I'm gonna go sort of in levels of
authoritarian.
The fight is now developing over whose authority
is it to reopen the country, which is really
about reopening individual states.
Not every state closed at the same time, not
every state fully closed.
And these were decisions made by governors
of different sort of levels of common sense
and rationality.
Donald Trump is claiming more and more that
it is his absolute authority to open up the
country.
Now, funny number one, that he says this because
he never closed the country.
He much later than many states had already
done it gave guidelines to states that they
should follow.
But more importantly, it's not funny at all.
It's actually scary because Donald Trump has
become downright dictatorial.
And that's the right word in his pronouncements
that
it is up to him and him alone.
And if a governor doesn't want to open up
a state, Trump has the sole authority, absolute
sole authority as president to force them
to do it.
Here is Trump escalating in his authoritarianism
and delusions of dictatorship.
What you're trying now?
Not at all.
Let me just a very simple I'm going to put
it very simply.
The president of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has the
authority to do, which is very powerful.
The president of the United States calls the
shots.
If we weren't here for the states, you would
have had a problem in this country like you've
never seen before.
We were here to back them up and we're back
in with more than back them up.
We did a job that nobody ever thought was
possible.
It's a decision for the president of the United
States.
Now, with that being said, we're going to
work with the states because it's very important.
You have local governments, they pinpointed
it's really you talk about it's like a microchip.
They have pinpointed we have local government
that hopefully
will do a good job.
And if they don't do a good job, I'd step
in so fast.
But no, they can't do anything without the
approval of the president.
So this runs directly counter to the Constitution,
the law, states rights, all of the things
that the people supposedly on Trump's side
have been fighting for for hundreds of years.
I mean, certainly decades in the modern era
of Republicanism.
Here's another specific question from a reporter.
And Trump is just not backing down.
He wants to be the authoritarian, but he also
wants to avoid any responsibility when things
go wrong.
Nothing is his responsibility, but everything
is his sole absolute authority.
More and more sounding like Kim Il-Sung and
Kim Jong Il and Kim Jong un and the like.
Take a look at this.
What is your understanding of your authority?
vis-a-vis governors, just leaders, specifically
princes.
If a governor issued a stay at home and you
say my authority is the president, is that
mind?
Because it's not me.
This is when somebody is the president of
the United States.
The authority is total.
And that's so it's going to be your authority
to total.
It's total.
And the governors know that if the governor
said you have a couple of bands of excuse
me, excuse me, you have a cup.
Could you say you have a couple of bands of
of Democrat governors.
But they will agree to it.
They will agree to put the authority of the
president of the United States having to do
with the subject.
We're talking about his total.
And then check out CNN Caitlin Collins here
pressing him about.
Has any governor said they agree that this
is your call?
Take a look at what Trump says he doesn't
want us to say.
He is.
That is not true.
We're going to write a paper on this.
Necessary because the governors need us one
way or the other, because ultimately it comes
with the federal government.
That being said, we're getting along very
well with the governors and I feel very certain
that there won't be a problem.
You have to decide when there is just enough.
He clearly had enough of Caitlin Collins and
these are good questions.
Does any governor agree with you on this idea?
Who gave you the idea that it is your absolute
authority?
So this is the way it works in a dictatorship.
It's not supposed to work this way in the
United States.
Now, I can assure you, if Trump says let it
rip on May 1st or even let it rip on May 15th.
Many governors are not going to say let it
rip.
California's Gavin Newsome is not going to
say, everybody get back out there, sports.
The entire thing.
Trump can't force Boston restaurants to open.
In fact, I don't even know that our governor
can force Boston restaurants to open.
How do you force a private business to open?
Right.
Trump can't force kids in San Francisco to
go back to school.
It's patently absurd.
But
the really scary part is the authoritarian
nature with which Trump claims he can control
every governor and every state and every business.
It's not even clear governors have some of
the powers.
Donald Trump is claiming he has and states
that are already sort of taking taking in
a following.
What Donald Trump is suggesting he's going
to do have already said, we're not listening
to Trump, we're listening to our health experts,
we're listening to doctors, not the president.
Now, this wasn't all.
Donald Trump also turned the White House corona
virus press briefing into a campaign propaganda
event.
Trump actually stepped aside at one point
and played on televisions, video of governors
saying nice things about him to, I guess,
prove what a great job he's been doing.
This is just a few seconds of it.
I won't play at all.
Mercy shut down here in Los Angeles.
That was directly because he sent it down
here.
Two thousand medical units came to the state
of California.
These FLSA, these these field medical stations.
And that's been very, very helpful.
The president has been outstanding through
all this.
The vise president's been outstanding members
of the Kronen virus task force, very responsive
and asked if we could have New Jersey could
have access to a piece of the beds that are
on the U.S. and comfort.
And the president came back called the a short
few minutes before I walked in here to say,
indeed, they would grant that to New Jersey.
So that's a big step for us in addition to
all the other capacity.
This was essentially a campaign video and
reporters realized this might, in a way, violate
campaign finance rules, asking Donald Trump,
was that video produced here at the White
House by administration staff to was done
in our state?
Just to be clear, this was witnessed by government
employees, hired by people here at the White
House.
This campaign style, I will use the word produced.
All they did was took some clips and they
just randomly.
And then lastly, the briefing started with
Anthony Foushee having to get up there, holding
his hat proverbially and saying, despite all
of the reports that I said, Trump could have
saved lives by closing and acting earlier.
Everything was done when I asked.
Everything is found.
Fine.
Foushee was then asked that Donald Trump tell
you to say this.
And here's how Foushee reacted voluntarily.
I'm doing everything I do as voluntarily.
Please don't even imply that now.
To me, it seems like a very reasonable question
to Anthony Foushee.
And voluntary can simply mean Trump lost his
you know what behind the scenes and Foushee
volunteered to make a statement in strict
terms.
Trump might not have told Foushee.
You've got to make a statement today.
But Trump can still flip out and make it clear
Foushee he needs to do something.
It struck me as one of those hostage.
Proof of life type videos.
They're treating me well and I'm being fed.
Really?
The stuff of nightmares.
And now I want to dig into one of the specific
elements of that propaganda video that Donald
Trump played.